[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that pretty good Dear John Hank
it's a comedy podcast in which two
brothers answer your dubious questions
nope answer your question gimme to be
surprised and bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John what yes the elephant in the room I
just want to say for the record that we
will be answering some dubious questions
in this episode ya know we usually do
usually sometimes I'm like I don't know
that this question is asking from the
perspective of a real situation or one
that was just made up but either way I'm
gonna do it because there's a good
question alright what's the oven room
John three two one Walter wait what Walt
Disney's signature Peng just made a
video about Walt Disney's signature that
is much better than it has any right to
be it is a really fascinating video and
actually Hank this is as close as we've
ever come to having the same elephant in
the room because I felt like that was
your version of the Anthropocene with a
little bit of an episode of the
Anthropocene reviewed in five minutes
with lots of graphics yeah I had a I had
a really good time doing it and but have
not I have not stopped being obsessed
with it I did not get to the bottom of
of it and I have been since the view has
come out some people have given me more
information and I have started to be
really interested in talking to some
people who are in their mid to late 80s
because I need to talk to them now
before all the good information they
have is gone Hank is going to get to the
bottom of how the D in the Walt Disney
logo came to be if it is the last thing
he ever does and it may be it may well
be the last thing he ever does it's
working I'm working hard I know I think
and your elephant in the room is your
own podcast I mean why not John why not
yours is your own most recent video so
I'm not going to apologize there is a
new episode of the Anthropocene review
that just came out we're taking a break
after this episode so go listen to this
one now because there won't be a new one
for a while the the most recent one is
about a seventeen thousand year old cave
painting of
hand stencil and the Taco Bell breakfast
menu did you did you have a good VidCon
John I did I had a very nice VidCon I
really enjoyed myself it was really
lovely
and I thought in many ways it was the
best VidCon ever and I'm hugely grateful
to the team who put it on and worked so
hard to make sure that it was a safe fun
event you know it occurs to me that we
sure did make this whole intro with with
in mind the fact that now is now and in
fact this episode may come out in months
well but the new episode of the
Anthropocene reviewed will be the new
episode of the Anthropocene reviewed
there like a couple months okay we don't
know when this one's gonna come out
because we recorded to this week because
I assume we're gonna be busy doing
something and somebody decided to
schedule us for two I'm Zoey I'm going
on vacation this first question comes
from Kelly who writes Dear John and Hank
have either of you ever gone for a high
five where the person you tried to
high-five didn't reciprocate or didn't
realize what was happening and left you
hanging I always have so much anxiety
about this to the point where I don't
even go for high-fives anymore since the
stakes and my hands are often too high
great good very well-written Kelly do
you have any advice on what to do with
my hands if I find myself in a
non-reciprocal high five humiliation
situation or am I doomed to remain
hanging high fives Kelly this I mean
this happened to me at VidCon at least
one time do I and I like what I did was
I went too high just as just as Kelly
said and people were confused by what I
was doing in there they were like that
looks like not the thing you should do
are you raising your hand would you like
to be called upon yeah and and then I
was like no high five me and so I like
which was not the most elegant solution
to be like is anybody gonna do the thing
because I'm sitting here and I can't it
is it's opening yourself up to a certain
amount of vulnerability and when you're
in that situation saying like high-five
me dang it is I think okay and I think
that that's showing like a certain
amount of confidence no because what if
somebody doesn't like applying their
palm microbes to your palm microbes I
don't want to put anybody under pressure
to exchange Paul Elliot
any initiation of a high-five is putting
people into that pressure so what you
just said is no one will ever high-five
again well I'm not saying no one should
ever high-five again I'm just saying
their hands are overwhelmingly the
filthiest part of the body you could you
could hi I'm up here for a high-five and
then you go elbows and I'm like yeah
elbows any any recognition or the the
the fist bump that Howie Mandel does I'm
a big fan of that Mandel fist bump I
actually have a solution to this problem
Hank I saw it happen live in an NBA game
and it was one of the most beautiful
things I'd ever seen you know how after
a free throw a lot of times like the
players high-five regardless of whether
they make the free throw just as a way
of kind of you know just ritualizing the
process in an attempt to make free
throws work better
no so but ok well that's a thing there's
a lot of high-fiving after free throws
that's all you need to know for this
this one time I saw a player like went
for a high-five just as all the other
players like turned around and was left
just holding his hand up and what he did
I thought this was brilliant was he
brought his other hand up and high-fived
himself and then he put both his hands
down and he just he was like I got you
it's a wonderful example of self-care
and it's a wonderful example of like
positive self-talk like they don't want
a high-five you well I know somebody who
does buddy it's yourself yeah I mean I
have a similar thought which is like
you're up there you're hanging just
fifth pop yeah also work just be like
this question comes from Francisco who
asks a dear Hank and John my wife and I
recently moved into a new state for work
opportunities I have made a good
impression on my boss and have been
entrusted to house it while he and his
family go to Australia for two weeks I
assume for VidCon Australia where to
where five days in and my wife has
locked us out the neighbor who
supposedly had a spare key and informed
us that they never received a key oh
love the podcast sincerely San Francisco
well you've been I've assumed that
you've been sleeping out on the rocks in
the front yard because I think that they
have xeriscaping not
not a lawn because these people are very
respectful of the water situation
wherever you live and so you can sleep
it on the rocks waiting for this vodcast
to come out which I appreciate greatly I
don't know if I've ever told you this
before Hank but this happened to a
friend of mine but it happened
immediately after their three-year-old
son closed the door Oh God so they went
to open the door and they realized that
the door had locked behind the guy Oh
mine are like five minutes they watched
the kid just like you know live in
complete freedom it's so like the kid
walked to the refrigerator like open the
refrigerator door and like rummaged
around closed it the whole time they
were free Jeffrey Jeffrey Jeffrey
Jeffrey open open open door open turn it
up turn the knob turn the knob and like
the kid couldn't but then of course like
the kid freaked out you know like it's
like fine for five minutes and then it's
a complete freak out situation and in
the end they had to take off their shirt
wrap it around their fist and punch a
hole in their glass door in order to get
back inside because they couldn't bear
to wait for a locksmith
so the situation isn't that bad
hopefully yeah ideally you just call a
locksmith and you're like listen I don't
own this home but the owners are in
Australia and trust me it's cool yeah
yeah you I swear you're not breaking
into this very nice house just for
writing yeah I I promise I've been in a
similar situation where I was asked to
cat sit and and and needed to break into
a house because the the place they had
not left the key where they said they
were going to leave the key and there
was no need and luckily one of the
windows was open and I just cut through
the screen and snuck in that way Wow
but if there's no way in you got it you
got are either locksmith you got to
break a window man yeah it's unfortunate
but I don't I don't see I don't see
another solution unless have you tried
the chimney don't try the chimney good
God Almighty what a terrible I mean this
is the thing houses are built to not get
broken into like it's the whole point
right not the whole point there's like
also you keep the rain off and stuff but
in general people like to make their
houses difficult to enter if you if you
would not like other people to enter
them this next question comes from Jess
who asks dear John and Hank when I was
in college an upperclassman showed me a
tumblr blog she ran about a mutual
friend let's call him Ian in it she and
some of her friends basically talked
about Ian like he was a fandom they
would write posts on ye and his awesome
discuss which girls they shipped him
with etc oh wow it was a little odd but
overall the blog was mostly harmless
however about a year after learning
about this blog I started dating Ian
actually we've been together for several
years now the problem is I've never told
Ian about this tumblr should i on one
hand there hasn't been a post on it in
years and neither Ian nor I kept in
contact with the girls who ran this blog
on the other hand I'm not sure how Ian
would respond to learning that such a
thing exists and that I've been keeping
it from him for so long
marriage feels like it might be in the
cards for us why should I just keep the
secret from him for the rest of our
lives and if I did tell him how would I
even bring it up any dubious advice
would be appreciated infinite Jess Oh
nicely done infinite Jess ok John I have
a very specific set of feelings about
this this blog was not about Ian correct
his blog was about the idea of Ian it
was about like they had like do you
create mythologies around people when
you're in social space yeah I did this
in high school all the time where there
were people who like I saw peripherally
and saw from a distance and like my
friends and I would make up like whole
stories about their lives that weren't
true when we knew they weren't true this
blog is not about Ian you know who Ian
is they did not know who he it is you
don't have to tell Ian about this but
but 10 years into your marriage that's
when you tell Ian
no like I have a ten-year anniversary
present for you there's something I've
been hiding for the last 20 years 15
years
i-i-i-i had I also had something like
this in high school there was this kid
who went to our high school and
everybody really loved him he was a
great guy and people made made stickers
you remember that Andre the Giant has a
posse sticker that was
popular in their early 90s we made
stickers of this guy and then we put
them all over the world actually like
even look at how man and what would it
be like to be well I guess you know now
cuz people do post put your stickers in
places do they yeah there's a there's a
bunch of Pizza John stickers in the
pizza restaurant buy my hat buy my oh
yes I guess there are paid to Jon
stickers out there and the answer to
what is it like is it's pretty weird but
I also like but what would it be like to
be a high school student and have people
like you well I think the big difference
was that I still think I get like 50
cents for every Pizza John sticker that
gets sold whereas I don't write this kid
ever made a dollar and I I highly doubt
that
Ian was paid for his likeness on this
tumblr um my feeling about it is that
it's fine to keep it a secret because
it's not about Ian but it's also fine to
tell him I don't think that he'll be
like shocked or freaked out I think
he'll be like oh that's weird and not
about me right it would be it probably
is a sort of thing to have come up
rather than something to bring up
because if you bring it up it sounds
like it's a big deal and I don't think
it is yeah I agree I don't think it
would be a big deal if it were like some
bullying burn book thing but it's not
like ian is awesome and we have made up
a whole mythology around Ian and all the
great things that Ian is and then it
turns out that ian is awesome so no
worries right but also normal also in
norm we don't know that for sure that no
point in Jessa's letter does she say
that Ian is not an amazing amazing
person who deserves to have many
tumblers written about him alright Jesse
I'm gonna hold you accountable now and
say we should find out more about Ian I
don't need to know everything I do need
to know everything Jess I want you to
write me a book-length introduction to
Ian okay it's official John asks for the
ask for that
no actually I'm gonna click that back I
don't want more than 200 words but I
want it to be extremely comprehensive
that sounds like this sounds more like
it this next question comes from Paula
who asks dear Hank and John I just
started a job a new adulty job right out
of college on the fifth floor of an
office building I love it but there's a
problem
the
elevator in the office building is
extremely slow because of this I have to
stand awkwardly next to people I don't
know four minutes hmm that is a slow
elevator yeah what makes it worse is
that there is no elevator music so we
stand there in silence is there
something I should do to make the
elevator ride less awkward
should I make small talk with the office
mates even though I never see them
outside of the elevator help me ah if I
could I'd climb up the wala
Paulo very good Paulo well I mean you
could climb up the stairs huh yeah that
that was gonna be my suggestion as well
have you have you considered the stairs
up because I the great thing about the
stairs is that you get a fair amount of
exercise and you don't have to encounter
strangers or if you do encounter them
it's in a weird situation where you're
sort of out of breath so you're not
expected to speak right
the this is this is like a legitimate
thing that I want to point out as
someone who climbs stairs every day at
the office or at my house I I'm like
stairs are no big deal and then when I
hit like the third flight if I'm in a
hotel or in the convention center or
something I'm like okay that's nothing
yeah I'm doing this still so five floors
is a lot like it's not like I'm not
saying you should be able to tell but
but a month into this it won't be a big
deal and it'll be faster than this slow
as everything elevator the only other
alternative I think is to on your cell
phone
play Kesha's woman every time you get
into the elevator close or any song
really because then you're just then you
get known at the office as the person
who plays elevator music for us but it's
all I think a whatever it is it should
be that it should be the same song every
day hey let's throw out some songs that
would be good songs for Paulette to play
every single day on her five minute
elevator ride in the morning
Margaritaville really solve it I'm a
believer by the monkeys Sweet Home
Alabama
very specific I don't know where the
house fell off this building again I
mean it's much better if it's in Maine
than if it's in Alabama
yeah I know money mo problems
by notorious b.i.g living on a prayer by
Bon Jovi that might be the bad we might
be done now that's it it's living on a
prayer by Bon Jovi Paula every single
day walk into that elevator the booming
noise of Bon Jovi cuz you are you're
halfway there you're on your way up if
probably by the time you get to that
part of the song you're halfway there
right exactly the best part about living
on a prayer is that it like begins with
that like thumping trouble yeah that's
not like the moment the elevator closes
it's just like alright I'm just gonna
play it for you actually it's coming
hold on hold up wait for it does I have
it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody's like well okay well I guess
we're doing this now day 672 have taken
the elevator with Paula this turned out
better than expected um I haven't had so
much fun on dear Hank of John since we
found out about Ross bag dodgy and
junior in the chipmunks John do you know
that song it's do you know what it do
you know what a double dactyl is I don't
know what a double dactyl is it is is it
a kind of dinosaur it's a no it's a
rhyme scheme oh that it's a it's a it's
a rhyme scheme that tends to be used in
just in poetry but but living on the
prayer actually has uses double dactyls
do you know that living on a prayer was
on that Bon Jovi album slippery when wet
which was the first cassette tape I ever
owned it was my third favorite song on
the free would wet behind on my favorite
song when I was 9 years old wanted dead
or alive oh man my second favorite song
now 9 year olds you give love a bad name
love that side did not understand the
theme of in 3rd grade when I first
listened to that album I imagine you
also did not understand the theme of
slippery when wet in fact I did not
understand it until just now when you
said it I apologize I want to go back in
time to when I thought it was a
reference to recently water wars no it's
just it's because he gets so sweaty on
stage next question great moving on I
mean it was so good until it all went
bad
Oh Dear John and Hank this question is
from Hannah Dear John and Hank as I was
strolling around the streets of San
Francisco I realized something that
puzzled me when you press that little
button that says something along the
line
of pressed to walk it doesn't seem to
hurry up the process of changing the
green light to red for pedestrians then
I thought that maybe the number of
people that press the button tells the
machines if they can change the light
but even if no one presses the button it
still changes what is the point of this
button dubious answers are appreciated
Hana sure like here's just a straight up
we had a bunch of fun just now so we're
gonna have straight-up answers they do
different things in different places Oh
in some places it's purely psychological
it's like if there's not a button people
are like that when is the Leica to
change for me and so they just put a
button there and it doesn't do it like
the closed door button in almost every
elevator except in Europe where I found
out that you actually oftentimes have to
push the closed door button which was a
very big huge surprise for me and I was
sitting there in the elevator being like
why am I not going anywhere anyway
there are also some buttons that are
there for like vision impaired people so
you push the button and it will tell you
it will give you updates in the
situation you can tell you to wait or to
walk right there are also buttons that
actually do have an impact but and those
are at intersections where the light
doesn't change unless a car pulls up or
unless somebody pushes the button and in
that case oftentimes the button push
will give you a longer light cycle a
longer green for the cars going through
the light and also you get that walk
time where you instead if you didn't
push the button you'd have a very quick
green for just the cars that would not
be quick enough for pedestrians so in
short it's just like life sometimes you
press a button and it matters and other
times you press a button and it doesn't
matter and you press the button the same
way regardless and yeah you never know
you just you just do you sort of do what
the panopticon is telling you to do mmm
okay Hank did you know that slippery
when wet the Bon Jovi album I'm sorry to
return to it but I'm not done yet
so the 3.4 million digital copies like
once digital music became a thing enough
people still love slippery when wet to
buy 3.4 million digital copies of it I
mean Anna Sui I assume that people had
already purchased a tape and possibly a
record and possibly a CD and then this
is like the fourth time they're buying
slippery when wet
yeah it's so good that we have moved
past this era we don't have to do this
anymore we just pay our $10 a month for
google play music or whatever YouTube
music I mean Spotify so I don't know
that it's good for Jon Bon Jovi and
Richie Sambora though linking members of
Bon Jovi into Jon actually did you know
that Richie Sambora I have terrible news
for you it's not a member of Jon Bon
Jovi's band anymore shut the front door
are you serious happen sometime creative
differences I'm sure oh my god he left
the band in 2013 how am I just hearing
this breaking news well I I also didn't
I just I just found out myself I have
too much Hank we have another question
this one comes from Troy and by the way
if we sound different that's because
it's a week and a half later Jon's
memory card got corrupted so we had half
a podcast and now we are cut again the
second half the podcast it's true that
my memory card cut corrupted but just
for the record it is not because I ate
the memory card which is what happened
last time my memory card got corrupted
so in a way this is progress
this was just an old-fashioned
technological failure not me trying to
eat a pretzel chip that turned out to be
a memory card this next question comes
from Troy who writes hello that's how
the email begins I work as a bookkeeper
for a very well-off small business and
have been for the past two years I
thought my wage was pretty decent given
that I don't work many hours but
recently the owner has gotten me to add
his wife to the payroll and her pay is
much higher than mine I asked what
exactly she was doing as I have never
seen her around the office and he said
that she was gonna take over some of the
audit work he does which is very little
and not worth the pay that she's getting
Oh Troy this has nothing to do with you
and everything to do with taxes
basically is it right for me to
negotiate a higher wage and use another
employees rate of pay as an argument to
increase mine since I do the payroll and
know every what everyone else makes or
is it wrong since that kind of
information is supposed to be
confidential I haven't fallen yet Troy
oh good good name specific sign-off yeah
John is right that this is a this is all
about tax loopholes and and it is a
little bit a little bit
I don't know how aboveboard it all is
it's very common it's very common for
this very Christmas is that
owned by one person or by a couple to
put both people in the couple on the
payroll as a way of shift there's a
bunch of advantages yeah there's a bunch
of advantages and also like you can put
more into your retirement accounts and
all this stuff but yeah it is very very
common thing to do I would argue though
that it doesn't have anything to do with
the value of your work Troy and I don't
think I'm general it's a good idea to
use information that should be
confidential to negotiate your salary
that said if you do think that you
deserve a higher salary you should go
and negotiate it I think that that's I'm
all for that I think people should do
that more often I think if you add a lot
of value to the company that you work
for mmm-hmm go in and make the case yeah
and the worst thing that can happen is
that the they'll be like in the the
situation we're in right now we really
don't want to do that we're you know and
and then maybe you'll know a little bit
more about how the company works and and
hopefully hopefully everybody realizes
that that's not an antagonistic
experience it is a you know it's it's
part of how businesses have to work
exactly this next question comes from
Nicole who asks dear Hank and John it's
currently the day before my birthday and
I had walked into work to see gifts from
my co-workers sitting on my desk you
have multiple desks that's amazing I
politely thanked them talked about my
plans for my birthday and then just went
to work I'm really happy they gave me
something but I have found myself in a
dilemma should I open their gifts right
away or should people wait until they
are in private to open gifts I used to
think it was disrespectful to open
birthday gifts in front of people but I
don't like coworkers to think I don't
appreciate them please help as I sit
awkwardly next to a small pile of
birthday gifts just short of a dime
Nicole oh there's like nickel nickel I
mean the quality of the specific sign
offs on this podcast have never been
higher also the quality of your
workplace like I feel like this is a
prank
like never have I ever been in a
workplace where someone had a birthday
and they received a small pile of gifts
yeah me neither we're like hey maybe
cake maybe there will be a balloon maybe
someone will bring in cookies when I
what that's cuz we all wouldn't want
cookies
when I worked at book West the rule was
that on your birthday you had to bring
in your own damn cake
yeah because otherwise you got to
remember when everybody's birthday is so
you get just youch cake but it's the
responsibility of the birthday owner to
bring in the cake I thought it was a
great solution anyway you are not under
any responsibility whatsoever to open up
these presents during work hours as a
business owner I feel very strongly
about that no you opened them up
afterwards and then you send notes you
said thank you write that because that
you appreciated the gifts I mean it
would be a like a very and like I don't
know where we are right now I don't know
I like I'm completely in left-field
I don't understand your workplace I
don't understand this like we have a
very supportive tight-knit workplace but
this would never happen and I can't
imagine any situation that's not like a
baby shower where our an adult is
surrounded by people as they open gifts
it's like it's such a it's super awkward
surrounded by like that in a baby shower
it's like your closest friends at work
it's like this is it like okay everybody
stand around while I find out what kind
of bobble head or action figure I was
given by Tony over an accounting I don't
know what do you get from co-workers
here's a but here's a can of Lucroy I
don't understand
hey I got you a digital download of
slippery when wet good call back John to
a week and a half ago thank you we
should mention by the way Hank that it's
been a fascinating week and a half since
we last awkward this bod surely has
which surely the biggest news by far
aside from the amazing moving
tear-jerking rescue of the wild boar
soccer team in Thailand which is just
beautiful and the best of humanity and
reminded me actually of your book Hank
because your book also explores the way
that how great humanity can be at its
best aside from that the big news of
course this week is that I am now a
character in the Marvel Cinematic
attic universe as a result of the
appearance of The Fault in Our Stars in
ant-man and the wasp which I can only
assume was a subtle and very generous
apology for the fact that the first
ant-man movie absolutely destroyed Paper
Towns at the box office when they came
out the same weekend I mean it is it is
uh it is ant-man but John you made
ant-man cry yes the eighth largest
franchise in all of Marvel I mean the
eighth largest franchise on all of
Marvel is still like it's like the tenth
largest franchise in all of everything
that's true that's a good point and I
should add that I'm very grateful to
have become a character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe rather than in the DC
Universe which is right now my very
least favorite universe I mean oh man
the things that are happening in the in
the DC character universe from Michael
Cohen on down continued to be
fascinating but not in a way that I want
to be part of uh I think that we are in
a transitionary moment where we do not
know what to do with the tools that we
have but eventually when we figure it
out things will be ok right John
I mean silver was very bad short-term
news for the world in the 17th century
and I mean I guess it got better today's
podcast is brought to you by Twitter
Twitter I guess it will get better
podcast has also brought to you by the
book of Ian the book of Ian it's a book
about everything to do with Ian don't
share it with Ian please and of course
today's podcast is also brought to you
by the cell 5 the cell 5 why high-five
someone else when you have your own
microbiome to high-five yourself with
and also this podcast is brought to you
by slippery when wet John hadn't thought
about that one very hard and now he has
I just want to go back just want to go
back in time to a more innocent age
today's podcast also brought to you by a
real sponsor our real sponsor is
brilliant you can go to brilliant org
slash dear Hank or brilliant org slash
Dear John I recommend the latter and if
you do that you can sign up for free and
also the first 200 people that go to
that link will get 20% off the
you will Premium Subscription and and
because learning stuff is one of the
best ways to feel like you're
progressing as a person and research
seems to indicate that one of the ways
we feel good and feel valuable is by
moving through a process of mastery
whether that's cooking or playing piano
or learning Spanish or probability or
logic or complex algebra physics
astronomy or machine learning or any
other dozens of things that you can
learn at brilliant org Hank all we have
in life is our attention it is the only
resource that we have in the end and one
of the things I like about brilliant is
that it calls me to use my attention a
little more carefully and a little more
thoughtfully to better understand the
universe and my place in it and I really
like it and I encourage everybody to
check it out you just go to brilliant
org that's where you check it out but if
you want to help our podcast you can go
to brilliant org dear John or brilliant
org slash dear Hank you get the first
200 people get 20% off the annual
premium subscription John yes we have
another question it's from Mindy who
asks dear Hank and John I need your help
I'm so confused about football scarves
yeah why did the scar why are the
scarves so short I feel like you know
the answer to this question you must
have the answer this question John
I would like to support our new
Minnesota United team goal uns that's
adorable and the marketing suggest that
I should get a scarf when I look at
football scars they seem really short as
a knitter and a person who lives in a
cold place I believe that a scarf should
be nearly as long as the wearer is tall
which allows for adequate coverage of
the face and neck and a head football
scarves aren't anywhere close to this
why nanu-nanu
Mindy so Mindy great reference to a
sitcom that nobody listening to this has
ever seen hey before you to the issue of
soccer scarves nanou reminded me of
comedians which reminded me that last
weekend I saw you cough Smirnoff in real
life in concert in Branson Missouri at
the Yakov Smirnoff theater in Branson
wait there's a Yakov Smirnoff theater
correct is he does he have like a
standing engagement he is there many
he had a standing engagement there for
like 25 years for those of you
unfamiliar with the FSB or not he is a
Russian American comedian who came to
the United States and I think 1977 from
the Soviet Union speaking no English
whatsoever and built a small empire
around being this like Soviet dissident
comedian and his catchphrase was America
what a country and he's very funny and I
have to say today Yakov Smirnoff is 67
years old he's playing in Branson I
would say the median age for the Yakov
Smirnoff show was 74
we would definitely yell happy by the
room and it was great he did a great job
he still has it he told a lot of the old
jokes he told a lot of the new jokes and
I I really enjoyed myself I was a little
dubious going in but like I enjoyed
myself so much and it made me think so
hard that there may be like a Yakov
Smirnoff revue in the Anthropocene
reviewed at some point that's how much I
liked it and that's how interesting I
found it anyway to get back to your
question Minnie
that was the whole thing that's it I
just wanted I just wanted to tell you
that I think a lot has happened in the
last week and a half and who wanna buy
me up to date I like I like that a lot
and I would like to interview Yakov
Smirnoff and be like what was what's it
been like to go to do the thing you did
yeah I just I want to know how to
transition you got it you gotta have so
many transitions in in a career as a
person who is a in the public eye and I
need to know how to do that because I
feel as if I have experienced some
already and they come with difficulties
yeah could I are deeply deeply
interested on how people deal with being
on what I call the other side of the
mountain like when you're on your way
down the other side of the mountain how
do you make it fun and meaningful one of
the ways that I make it fun and
meaningful Hank just just to give you a
piece of advice is I remind myself that
there were lots of things that I did not
like about the previous side of the
mountain that's true anyway to get back
to your question
which was about football scarves the
reason is that most football teams do
not play in Minnesota and most people do
not need scarves that are as long as the
person is tall so I think there's two
reasons for this one is that you know in
in England and France and other places
where football started in the early 20th
century shorter scarves made sense
because they were cheaper to make they
required less stuff and they were
adequate for the covering of the neck
and then the second reason is that the
football scarf is partially intended as
a thing that you hold up above your head
and it needs to be the approximate width
of your arms when they are held above
your head in a Y like you're doing the
beginning of the YMCA in the village
people song right and so that is the
proper length for a football scarf and I
know that it says in Minnesota but
you've got to remember most of us aren't
in Minnesota so when here when you're at
a football game and you have your
football scarf are you wearing your
football scarf like a scarf or is it
just like sitting on your lap getting
ready for you to shake it oh I think if
it's cold you're definitely wearing it
as a scarf and then if you not wearing
just like draped over like is it just
draped or is it rat i drape it unless
it's properly cold and then I ran okay
so here's the situation
Lindy you need two scarves you need a
regular normal scarf which you appeared
to probably have plenty because you're a
knitter and also you live in Minnesota
and then a route like you've got your
scarf on and then you have your football
scarf that just drapes across it's like
wearing a spike it's like wearing a pin
that says like I like the loons but it's
a scarf and it's like it's there to let
people know and it's it is a purely
decorative scarf it appears that's
exactly I think that's a good way to
think about it Hank oh just double scarf
the situation nobody in Minnesota ever
regretted having a second scarf in
winter absolutely yes have two scarves
you like you're not gonna complain about
having another piece of fabric but John
business idea really long scarves for
the Minnesota United team
it's like you and I we're gonna make
dozens of dollars it's not the worst
business idea you've had in the last
week and a half but yeah actually I was
gonna say but it's also not the best but
actually it is the best all right this
next question comes from Tristan who
writes Dear John and Hank but mostly
Hank I discovered Brotherhood 2.0
through eco geek a very long time ago by
Wow a very long time ago back in 2007
thank you for sticking with us all this
time Tristan every now and then I check
in on eco geek to see if it has been
updated the last two updates are both in
January of 2017 and 2018 respectively
after the name change took complexly for
your company I figured eco geek would
fully die but what is it with this weird
zombie state for something that you used
to care so much about P&P
Tristan parties in power pumpkins at
Penguins Pride and Prejudice it's what I
would I always think what somebody puts
B&P yeah I mean there when when I
transitioned out from from being
somebody who was working day to day on
eco geek because because the videos
things had had taken over so much that
was in part because like I had so much
stuff to do it was also in part because
like I wasn't as enthusiastic about that
project anymore because a lot like
blogging was changing and there was a
lot of consolidation going on and people
and it was sort of like I would either
have to like put my like make eco geek a
blog on a bigger network or I was gonna
have to not do it anymore and also like
I was kind of the way to get people to
click on articles felt it was just too
much too much clickbait for me to make
it feel valuable so there were things I
did actually didn't like about it so I
kind of gave it over to some of the
other writers and I was like keep keep
this up but if and when you want to and
it is still really remarkable to see it
there and also that like the design of
eco geek hasn't you know ten years later
it looks not super stale yeah but I
think mostly because the Internet has
come all the way back around like
bell-bottoms are back
like for a while it did look stale but
now like we're back to white mostly
empty pages and I'm like eco geek looks
pretty good these days oh man
well I yeah and I think that's largely
the the situation and and also in
general like he got it like there there
are parts of life that will come and go
and and and and it still exists though
because if part of me is always like we
should be doing something with this
there should be an eco geek YouTube
channel or something because I still do
obviously I care a lot about the topic
still yeah my feeling has always been
that some things on the internet and
some ways and other things and other
ways and it's like life sometimes it
goes out with a bang and sometimes with
a whimper and I don't mind things
continuing to be there and to live in
small ways I know I understand the urge
to want closure or to want an ending for
things but I guess one of the things I
like about the Internet is that things
often don't end in that straightforward
way that feels more true to me yeah yeah
Hank before we get to the all-important
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want
to ask you one last question it's from
Megan it's a big one it's complicated
it's hard to get into but it's also a
beautiful question Dear John and Hank
who is mr. Rogers Megan oh no I know
well but if you're a young person you
might not know who mr. Rogers is except
insofar as all the kindnesses that your
parents have ever shown you come
directly from mr. Rogers that we have a
little book that sits on our downstairs
toilet it's just a bunch of mr. Rogers
quotes and and if you should get that
book and just have it on your toilet
because it's way better than looking at
Twitter while you're going to the
bathroom yeah there's also a great mr.
Rogers documentary yeah just come out
that's really really powerful and moving
and kind of a bomb in these times mr.
Rogers was a children's television host
on public television who
who also was a source of kindness in the
world mm-hmm
yeah just a really thoughtful empathetic
person a you know a I don't know I don't
know how I don't know how he happened
but it's it's a it's marvelous that he
did because I know even now like we are
starting to watch Mister Rogers with
aura and though of course he doesn't get
what's happening most of the time but
like Kathryn and I are like this is this
is great thank you mr. Rogers I feel
better about stuff and also like that
was some good advice and I'm like this
is for this is for children but I am
really I need this right now not like I
need it like to bomb my soul like I need
this advice right no I completely agree
I mean mr. Rogers remains extremely
relevant I do think that in our secular
world one of the things that we need
that we are struggling to find or
haven't quite found yet is a version of
sainthood and obviously Saints are not
perfect people and Mister Rogers was not
a perfect person but if you're gonna
have a saint I think you could do worse
yeah I mean it's really it is nice to
have people that you can definitely look
up to tell you my Dodger story Hank yeah
yeah mr. Rogers worked in Pittsburgh and
I said about hit the car that got stolen
it is you told that story on the podcast
okay can I tell you mr. Rogers story
Hank so mr. Rogers worked and lived in
Pittsburgh that's where they made the
show and The Fault in Our Stars movie
was filmed in Pittsburgh and mr. Rogers
mr. McFeely from the show remember mr.
McFeely the mail guy of course mr.
McFeely happened to find out that we
were filming The Fault in Our Stars and
I don't know if it was him or his
nephews and nieces or kids or granting
or what somebody was a fan of The Fault
in Our Stars and mr. McFeely came to the
Fault in Our Stars set and was so kind
and lovely and wonderful to us and gave
us all this mr. Rogers
stuff for our kids and Daniel Tiger
which is the show that mr. Roger Studios
makes now and we you know have like
being able to take that stuff home to my
kids with such a wonderful memory and I
am it was just a wonderful little tiny
thing sometimes people can do little
tiny things that you know make make a
big impact on your life so thank you to
mr. McFeely and thank you to mr. Rogers
and now Hank now it is time for the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I can't
believe you met mr. McFeely oh he was so
nice - man that's is that like very
jealous is that like the coolest
celebrity encounter I've ever had I mean
I honestly maybe no no for me it was a
meeting Dwayne the rock Johnson you met
Dwayne the rock Johnson he handed me an
MTV Movie Award not to brag that's not
really meeting I mean I uh I looked at
it I saw his bicep up real close my eyes
were maybe it's good Warda five inches
away from his body did you see it's all
guy I don't know if he's a tall guy or I
was just hunched over real bad because I
was nervous about level with his bicep
also you gotta remember his biceps go
like all the way up to his shoulder you
know what's real weird to me that I had
I did have a hard time sort of
processing yeah that Hulk Hogan is six
seven I up a little I would have a hard
time processing that except I once was
on a plane with Hulk Hogan so I know
exactly how tall we is have I never told
you this story you you meet too many
people I've seen almost every celebrity
on a plane every celebrity who travels
via commercial aircraft I have been on a
plane with so Hulk Hogan I was on a
plane with Hulk Hogan I was seated in
coach and he was seated in first class
but a he stood for the entire flight
like
moment the fasten seatbelt sign went off
he stood up and he stood facing the rest
of the plane just like staring out at us
and the most amazing detail Hank is that
unlike most celebrities he was dressed
precisely as Hulk Hogan like he was not
wearing sunglasses he was not trying to
disguise himself in any way he was like
yes it is Hulk Hogan on your plane me
Hulk Hogan staring at you for the next
hour and 15 minutes well when you're 6-7
you don't want to sit down you want to
stand up
you know the celebrity I've been on a
plane with most often oh my is it John
Green what's happening right now
well Snoop Dogg I've been on a plane
with Snoop Dogg four times what four
times at that point you're just like
okay I guess we're friends right I met
snoop backstage at a thing once and we
took a picture together because I guess
his kids like my books or whatever and
he was very nice and everyone I've
talked to about snoop because I've sat
next to his manager or people several
times they all speak highly of him but
he does a much better job of disguising
himself than Hulk Hogan that's all I'll
say
ah so maybe I have set next to snooze
it's very possible it's very possible I
think at some point we promised some
people some Mars news so I'm gonna do
that instead of like who's John been on
a plane with before you guys can't wait
for my new spin-off podcast people I've
shared a plane with so I yeah so the the
the news of Mars is that so there's a
meteorite a beautiful little meteorite
in fact it's called black beauty that's
what they call it the scientists because
it's a pretty little black meteorite
that's from Mars and this you know we
have previous models of how Mars formed
and when Mars first became sort of like
like the crust formed and then rain fell
so there's this sort of this window
between which like there was definitely
liquid water on Mars and then it stopped
being there and then when it started
being there is basically the moment when
there was a crust so that is the window
which life could have happened and so
knowing that those those dates is
important and the models the
mathematical models we have for how Mars
would have formed indicates that the
crust formed pretty late later like
later than this now this new evidence is
showing us so instead of like a hundred
million years to before the the crust
formed it would have been more like 20
million years according to an analysis
of this meteorite which scientists did
science to to sort of like say like okay
this this rock is a very old rock from
the surface of Mars and we can tell from
I think the zircon crystals in it that
this rock formed just 20 million years
after the formation of the solar system
rather than like a hundred or a hundred
50 million years after the formation of
the solar system which was our previous
guess so that's pretty big news and it's
uh it does it does you know it has a
pretty big impact on how we're imagining
the the sort of window of potential life
on the surface of Mars that's really
interesting so is it possible that there
was life on Mars like long before there
was life on Earth yeah well yeah yeah I
mean there's sort of the the that
hypothesis is out there that like if
there was if there if we do find some
evidence of former life on Mars we could
we'll be able to tell whether that life
has shares of common ancestry with us so
was that life and like if it doesn't it
will actually be really hard to figure
out if it if it counts because all that
things we have to test for life are all
based on our chemistry but but you know
like the the idea that life could have
gone from Earth to Mars and then like
all the Mars life just got knocked off
of Earth on a meteorite or that it came
from Mars to earth and we are in fact
all descendants of Martian microbes
right which would be really neat I would
be amazing if after all of these decades
of work to get humans to Mars it turns
out that we were Martians all along and
if that is the case John question does
that mean we've already been
so we got there before 2028 if
definitive proof is discovered that we
are all Martians at some point before
2028 or after 2028 we will either
continue to keep the podcast name dear
Hank and John or we will change it back
yes so there is a chant but I mean I
want proof I don't mean like climate
change is real proof I mean proper proof
very clear that was a joke that was a
joke a joke for Hank and climate change
is real and that was that was the joke
ok the news from AFC Wimbledon Hank
there is so much news from AFC Wimbledon
we've lost all of our players and we've
gained entire an entirely new set of
players we've played some friendly games
at which these new players have had to
encounter each other presumably for the
first time yesterday
Neil hardly said that he is still trying
to sign wait for it seven more players
oh my goodness gracious
the season starts in like a month Neil
hardly would like to have at least seven
more signings for AFC Wimbledon this
summer so that is that is from South
London press and Mercury which i think
is a South London's leading AFC
Wimbledon newspaper alright so I would
want to introduce you to some of our new
players first off we have a new
goalkeeper it's a shame because I really
like George long he was great but our
new goalkeeper is named Tom King he
which lends itself to lots of puns so
congratulations Tom he's excited too
okay I think he's on loan he is on loan
from Millwall we've had a lot of players
on loan from Millwall over the years
we've had a good relationship with
Millwall they've provided us with some
of our best players so I'm all for it I
love I'm excited about Tom King we also
have a new striker
his name is James Hansen and he is a big
big lad he's 30 years old he's six six
feet four inches tall and in the past
AFC Wimbledon has done well when we've
had huge strikers who were difficult to
deal with the most famous being of
course auto-buy a walk and phenoix but
there are lots of other examples as well
so that that's exciting news
we got a new midfielder whose name is
Mitch Pinnock Mitch pinic hey all I know
is that on Twitter he calls himself
Mitchie pins
really that's Mitchie pin that sounds a
lot like something you'd make up yeah I
agree with you a hundred percent it does
sound like something I would make up but
his name is your phrase of the week
Mitchie pin Mitchie sins anyway I really
hope he scores a lot of goals because I
want to say the words Mitchie pins all
the time I don't even know if it's good
news or bad news but that's his name
Mitchie pins and we also signed a player
on loan named tonigh Watson who is a
defender he played for reading people
are excited about him
what keep her fingers crossed I guess I
have no idea if he's any good he's young
then he looks driven based on the one
picture of him that I've seen so yeah
that's the deal we've got some some new
players and there was also an
interesting meet the manager event at
which Neil hardly was asked a bunch of
questions about last season and one of
the things that he said is that he was
upset that some kind of cliques formed
and then he felt like the team wasn't on
the same page and that some of the
players who've been released or moved on
he felt like were maybe part of that
problem so now hopefully we'll have this
sort of like unified Squad who all buy
into the to the plan our preseason
results so far have been excellent we
beat Redding preseason it doesn't really
matter because a lot of times you know
teams are starting not their best
players to see who's good or who plays
well together or whatever but we beat
reading for two and Joe Pickett scored a
goal or as I call them
Joey pig's question I also scored a goal
I can't think of a quasi axe I'm get
ready for this all season long it's
never gonna stop every every week no
matter who scores I'm gonna report on
the exploits of Mitchie Mitchie pins no
matter what anyway so that's the update
we've had a good preseason things seem
to be going well
but it's entirely new players so I don't
know whether to be excited or terrified
John I think that you should be excited
I think that you should be excited you
guys all right guys are spending your
cash and I think you're doing it wisely
now it's time for the phrase of the week
which I can definitively say you didn't
say because you said it last podcast and
I still know what it is what was it
something about treadmills
it was treadmill shuffelin which was cam
mousse dance move and I did say it last
time and I got away with it you didn't
it was incredibly impressive but
unfortunately the memory card didn't
work so I apologize to camu signature
dance move who donated that for the
project for awesome and I even though
you did say your phrase of the week last
time I don't flip and remember it what
is it if double dactyl from Sierra so
did thank you but I will say that I did
not that slippery when wet or whatever
song I was talking about back then does
not have double dactyl sin and I lied to
you and I was very hard for me to keep
lying to you but I did that and and
powered through and didn't bring up the
fact that I was lying which was hard
right so the double dactyl rhyme scheme
does not appear in any song on slippery
when wet Bon Jovi's classic album
however there is a double dactyl rhyme
scheme example on wikipedia involving
our favorite president Benjamin Harrison
wait one side was boring and I got a lot
of trouble for saying he was boring so
I'm gonna read you this poem that I did
not write I did not write and I do not
agree with its theme it is a poem by
John Hollander higgledy-piggledy
Benjamin Harrison 23rd President was and
as such served between Cleveland's and
saved for this trivial idiosyncrasy
didn't do much wow wow wow that is very
weird
that is a very weird convergence of
something dumb and silly and something
dumb and silly suddenly having a large
large overlap on this podcast speaking
of which we have a project for awesome
message from Boyer to read to Jess
Boyer thank you for donating to the
project for awesome
Jess this is your message the post
office isn't hiring in Fairbanks so I
guess you have to move back to Iowa now
is that like a code that I just like did
I just send the Russians a message from
Donald Trump don't use us this way
there's lots of ways to communicate on
the internet now seriously Michael Cohen
what did I just tell what did I just
tell that russian pop star who organized
the meeting at Trump Tower anyway if
you're real person Boyer and Jess I hope
that that message meant a lot to you or
alternately that the post office starts
hiring in Fairbanks because it is a
lovely town
all right John thank you for making a
podcast with me thank you everyone for
listening to this podcast which is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our head of community in
communications is Victoria bon giorno
the music that you're hearing right now
and at the beginning the podcast is from
the great gunnarolla and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]